hello Sunday marks 20 years since the
start of operation Iraqi Freedom the U.S
led Invasion that toppled Saddam Hussein
the military operation was launched
without U.N support unlike the first
Gulf War or the invasion of Afghanistan
our diplomatic editor James Bays looks
at how The Invasion damaged The
credibility of the United Nations
U.N weapons inspectors in Iraq their job
to track down the country's chemical and
biological weapons we now know there
weren't any the former Iraqi ruler
Saddam Hussein that ceased his wmd
program years earlier but in 2003 U.S
President George Bush backed by the
British Prime Minister Tony Blair was
saying he was hiding a huge stockpile
and they claimed they had the
intelligence to prove it
the U.S Secretary of State Colin Powell
now known to have been privately
skeptical himself tried to make the case
in the security Council even wielding a
vial he said could be anthrax
the US and UK bitterly opposed by much
of the International Community including
France and Germany failed to get a
security Council resolution to authorize
a war they launched one anyway
in the aftermath one British Diplomat
who'd worked as his country's expert on
Iraq in the security Council resigned do
you think the United Nations ended up
damaged or strengthened by the war 20
years ago I I think without doubt it was
damaged by it the Secretary General of
the United Nations didn't assert his
authority to say that the war was
illegal and should not happen which
later he admitted and I think
collectively the quote unquote U.N this
sense of a global community of Nations a
sense of a shared set of rules took a
very big hit as a result of the Iraq War
so where does that leave things now 20
years on once again the Security Council
is deeply divided and there's no doubt
that the invasion of Ukraine by Russia a
permanent member was a breach of
international law and of the UN Charter
but Western diplomats when you speak to
them privately will tell you that their
efforts to put pressure on Moscow are
even now hindered by the memory of what
happened two decades ago
the run-up to the war in Iraq in 2003
was marked by Defiance and
disinformation resulting in deep damage
to the UN system and the rule of law
around the world so much may have
changed since but the repercussions of
events that haunted the UN then are
still being felt James Bay's Al Jazeera
at the United Nations
we have our correspondent Osama bin
javaid who's joining us from Baghdad so
Osama it's been two decades of change
and upheaval for Iraqis what do they
believe that they've lost and gained
but it depends on who you speak to here
in the capital Baghdad many people are
going about their business as they Mark
20 years there isn't anything to
commemorate most Iraqis would tell you
that in the last 20 years yes there have
been improvements but in comparison to
what they've lost it there's no there is
no equation there they will tell you
that they've lost Social Security
they've lost the sense of cohesion in
their society and they've lost in Iraq
which used to stand on its own feet Iraq
stands divided along sectarian and
ethnic lines and Iraq has not been able
to find its place economically and
politically to stand amongst the nations
in these last 20 years Iraqis have faced
the burst of Wars which started with the
invasion then they were sectarian Wars
and then came isil and only now they've
started to recover from what was the
mess that was left behind but we were
went to the city of Basra in Southern
Iraq where we ask people because that
used to be the flash point of one of the
first pitched battles were fought there
and we asked people there what do they
think of the invasion
's famous Italian bridge wasn't here 20
years ago neither was the main road that
leads to Buster's International Stadium
now the streets are peaceful and there's
relative political calm in this city and
across Iraq
we've achieved more than eight billion
dollars of foreign investment up to
February 2023 we are Keen to achieve
major projects this is all in
coordination with the federal government
lots of projects were completed in Basra
related to infrastructure Services
commercial and tourism sectors
this oil field is named majnoon which
means crazy in Arabic some say that
refers to the large amount of oil
reserves found here in one location an
estimated 38 billion barrels the Muslim
field produces 240 000 barrels a day for
Iraq's economy and production is planned
to be expanded to five and a half
million barrels per day
Iraq's government says despite obstacles
like corruption red tape and an unstable
region investors are lining up they're
mainly interested in the country's
abundant deposits of gas but despite its
large hydrocarbon resources Iraq Imports
a third of the gas it needs for its
power stations
nearly two billion dollars worth comes
from Iran and on a stretch budget that's
a burden
Iraq also spends an estimated five
billion dollars on importing diesel in
petrol
that's left Iraq's currency struggling
against the dollar and that's not all
original
as estimated by a parliamentary
committee corruption costs around 10
billion dollars a year around 600
billion dollars have been smuggled out
of Iraq in the past years we have to
fight against corruption Administration
and financial there's no real
development in the Iraqi economy
despite that wealth millions of Iraqis
struggle to get clean water every day
and every year thousands of people fall
ill due to waterborne diseases crank
rivers and climate change has increased
risks of food shortages
two decades ago the first battles of the
Iraq War were fought in bastra a city of
a million people was besieged by mainly
British forces clusterminations were
used and the International Coalition to
ban uranium weapons says UK and U.S
forces use depleted uranium
twenty years after the invasion a lot
has changed yet this province continues
to remain the backbone for Iraq's
oil-based economy but still the
complaints of the people are a lack of
jobs opportunities infrastructure and a
lack of attention from the people in
power
bathroom
well 20 years later a quarter of Iraq's
population remains below the poverty
line a number that has increased in the
last few years Iraq's deposits in its
foreign reserves have risen to a hundred
billion dollars yet on the streets of
Baghdad when you go around people will
tell you that the infrastructure is
there from the time of Saddam nothing
seems to have changed for them not
schools not hospitals not basic services
and that is according to them what is
the legacy of the U.S led Invasion which
has left Iraq in tatters and not enough
has been done to bring it back on its
own feet thank you so much Osama bin
Javed reporting from Baghdad